after the violent upheaval of
afghanistan's takeover finally revealed
who will run the new country they're not
pragmatic moderates in the taliban's new
cabinet a rose gallery of old guard
hardliners
look no further than this man sarajdean
haqqani a wanted man in the eyes of the
u.s department of justice that calls him
a specially designated global terrorist
he's now afghanistan's new interior
minister
muller omar was the notorious one-eyed
leader of the taliban at the time of 9
11. his son yakub is afghanistan's new
defense minister
and this is the new prime minister
muller hassan akund one of the taliban's
founding figures and associate of miller
omar
the actual leader of the taliban mullah
akunzada is not in the cabinet but is
likely to remain the power behind the
throne the hardline cabinet makes
dealing with the taliban much more
problematic for outside powers
they're really in a tough position of
how do they isolate a hard core taliban
regime at the same time of minimizing
the pain on
the afghan citizenry and those two are
almost impossible to reconcile
the hardline makeup makes dealing with
the taliban even more problematic for
outside powers as do these scenes on the
streets of kabul today
women and girls found the courage to
protest against the taliban despite its
reputation for treating them brutally
this was the taliban's response
gunfire in the air as the crowds ran for
cover and protesters were pursued
through the streets by taliban security
forces
if the taliban wants support from the
outside world to run afghanistan scenes
like these will make it much harder
but it may need it if it has any chance
of saving the country from a rapid slide
into economic collapse and chaos dominic
waghorn sky news